el post break 7 aumenta las tensiones
entre francia y reino unido
el martes londres anunció la aprobación
de la licencia de pesca en sus aguas
territoriales para 12 barcos franceses
de los 47 solicitantes y el miércoles la
isla de jersey dependiente de la corona
británica de negocio 35 solicitudes
galas esta decisión no ha gustado en
francia
la respuesta es primero decir que estas
decisiones son completamente
inaceptables e inadmisibles porque
infringen el acuerdo que se firmó en el
marco del presi a la corte
entre los acuerdos del break si te
existen fricciones en dos de los tres
puntos acordados para la transición
prevista hasta 2026 entre 12 y 200
millas náuticas de la costa británica no
hay problemas estos empiezan en la
franja de 6 a 12 millas naúticas de la
costa desde el sur del mar del norte
hasta galés los buques que ya ocupaban
esa zona tienen acceso garantizado hasta
2026 sin embargo francia dice que 75
buques esperan respuesta mientras que
londres dice que son 47 distinguiendo
embarcaciones nuevas de las que ya
pescaban antes del break city por último
la mayor fuente de conflictos son las
islas del canal jersey girl y donde los
barcos franceses deben proporcionar
pruebas de 11 días de pesca entre el 1
de febrero de 2017 y el 30 de enero de
2020 los derechos de pesca fue uno de
los principales obstáculos en las
negociaciones del break sheet para reino
unido es un sector simbólico para la
unión europea representa el 40 por
ciento de la pesca de la flota europea
francia estudia respuestas contundentes
vamos a identificar y decidir cuáles son
las respuestas que vamos a dar lo que he
propuesto a los profesionales es dar o
darnos 15 días para preparar todas estas
medidas
y post en mayo decenas de barcos
franceses rodearon el puerto de jersey
reino unido- respondió sacando a dos
patrulleras de la armada a lo que
francia amenazó con cortar el suministro
eléctrico ayer sí que depende en un 95%
del país galo